Have you ever crave something you've never had before,
but it sounds so good in your mind?
That's what happened to me today,
and that happens a lot now that I'm pregnant.
So today I decided to act on it
and make exactly what I was craving,
which was papaya and lime whipped cream.
So I started by zesting my lime
and then adding some heavy cream to my mixer.
And so I was craving something sour.
I added a whole lime to my heavy cream
and some powdered sugar.
I got distracted at this point
so I over whip my cream,
but it was still fine.
I added all of my lime zest into my cream
and folded it in.
Then I cut my very ripe papaya in half and deseeded it.
There's nothing better than papaya and lime.
So I added even more lime to my papaya
before I blend in my whipped cream,
just to give it a little bit more texture.
I also added a sprinkle of coconut sugar on top
and this was so delicious.
It was actually exactly what I was craving.
And now watching this video back,
I actually need to go make them again.